as
our biggest planet jupiter's
immense presence helps to hold our solar
system
together its massive size and
gravitational pull
give it a dense atmosphere a
turbulent mix of hydrogen and helium
this results in unfathomable storms
that have lasted for centuries
but let's imagine jupiter came in closer
contact with
an even bigger object the sun
would the sun strip jupiter of its
atmosphere
and if so what would that look like
what makes jupiter such a unique
gas giant what is jupiter's core made of
and what are hot jupiters and hot
neptunes
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if jupiter lost its atmosphere
jupiter's gravity is nearly two and a
half times
stronger than earth's making it
difficult for
any atmosphere to escape thankfully
it also keeps out incoming asteroids
jupiter has dense layers of gas
consisting of
90 hydrogen 10 helium and
a few traces of ammonia sulfur
methane and water vapor it has
an extended dilute core made up of rocky
material
ice hydrogen and helium and
unlike earth there's no sharp transition
between
jupiter's core and its outer atmosphere
scientists believe the core could have
been formed from
a head-on collision about four and a
half
billion years ago between jupiter and a
planetary
embryo 10 times more massive than earth
a recent discovery of the exoplanet ltt
9779b by nasa's
transiting exoplanet survey satellite or
tess may unlock even more answers to
jupiter's formation
and possible destruction
you know if you're watching this video
to help with your studies well then
good on you what if explorer you know
while getting the right facts
are essential to a good essay having
exceptional grammar
can take you from a b-plus to an a-plus
thankfully with grammerly premium
improving your writing is easy and
intuitive
with grammarly premium you can write
like a pro with advanced real-time
feedback
it's the perfect writing tool for anyone
who wants to stand out with every word
and if you're a little verbose like me
well grammarly premium offers clarity
and vocabulary suggestions
to keep your sentences clear and concise
and grammarly supports
several platforms with their desktop
editor browser plugin and mobile apps
they're available
pretty much everywhere i type now
grammarly doesn't just correct your
mistakes
it helps you build up your skills as a
writer you can elevate your writing now
with
twenty percent off grammarly premium by
signing up at grammarly.com slash what
if
that's twenty percent off grammarly
premium at g
r a m a r l y
dot com slash what if nasa's discovery
of the jupiter-like exoplanet
ltt-9779b has
captivated the scientific community with
its miraculously close
orbit to its star while jupiter
maintains a safe distance from the sun
ltt 9779b
is so close to its star that its
atmosphere
is evaporating at an accelerating pace
what makes it so unique is that close
orbits
are usually reserved for earth-like or
jupiter-like planets but ltt-9779b
is somewhere in between closer in scale
to neptune
with an hot temperature of about
1725 degrees astronomers have
unimaginatively named it hot neptune
i am clever guys personally i would have
gone with
the blue inferno
astronomers believe that the exoplanet
may have
formed further away from its star and
has slowly made its way closer and
closer over millions of years
the closer it gets to its star more
and more of its atmosphere evaporates
giving it a squished almost
football-like appearance
american football ltt 977b
is losing its atmosphere because it
has surpassed the critical distance
where a planet
begins to lose mass due to the tidal
forces
caused by another celestial body this
is known as the roche limit luckily
jupiter is far enough away from the sun
to maintain its mass
and its moons are far enough away from
jupiter
not to be absorbed so
why do most gas giants like jupiter
reside so far away from the sun
well all planets were built in the same
way
the sun's gravity pulled dust and rock
together
while the sun burned off gases such as
hydrogen and
helium in the inner solar system the
outer parts
stayed cool this provided just the right
temperature
and materials for planets to form
atmospheres some astronomers have
suggested that there
are earth-like planets out there that
may have once been gas giants
for unknown reasons they have entered
the roach limit and
lost all their atmosphere becoming hot
earths
there are even hot jupiters out there
like
the exoplanet 51 peg
which is similar in scale and orbits its
star
every four days for jupiter to start
losing
its atmosphere it would need to come
closer to the sun and
surpass its roche limit while this isn't
likely to happen
if jupiter got nudged toward the sun it
would slowly
start to spiral closer and closer to it
it would lose more mass with each orbit
eventually it would get so close that it
would
orbit the sun in a single day 88 times
faster than mercury's orbit the sun's
strong solar winds would give jupiter a
tail of gas like a comet this
enormous amount of gas could cloud the
light of
many stars making our night sky
much less impressive during this slow
process
jupiter would be squished and eventually
lose its atmosphere it would be left
looking like
a barren rocky planet like mercury but
about the size of 11 earths
as we continue to explore and discover
more exoplanets like
hot jupiters or hot neptunes scientists
can
better understand planet formation which
is
vital to our understanding of the
universe
maybe jupiter losing its atmosphere
could be a good thing with all that gas
it could be the perfect fuel to jump
start the sun
when it's running low but as always
that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you